There is an animal out there
they will steal your shoes,
can play catch with
a ball, and can
look at you with
intelligent eyes.
But you probably wouldn't
want this one as a pet.
Hey, guys, Trace here for D
News to open your mind a bit.
What's in a brain?
That which we call a mind
by any other configuration
we'd think is sweet,
or so it turns out.
In case you're not into
paraphrasing Shakespeare,
it's come to light that
many of our assumptions
about large brains
have been off the mark.
The human brain is
a centralized organ
inside the head that
controls and manages
all the functions
of the human body.
Everything happens in here.
Involuntary, voluntary,
emotion or logic--
it's all made in one spot.
The human brain is
a pretty large size
considering our body.
It's almost twice as
large as it should be.
We're pretty smart with
this centralized CPU.
But what if we networked
a bunch of brains?
Would we be even smarter?
Right now, we can solve puzzles
and mazes, we can open jars,
we use tools, we
can steal things,
we can hide from predators,
we can play with toys,
we can recognize faces,
and a bunch of other stuff.
But an octopus?
It can do all that too.
Are you surprised?
Slowly, humans have been finding
out that the animals around us
are a lot smarter
than we thought.
And the lowly octopus is kind
of like an animal genius.
The cephalopod and the human
share a common ancestor
from 750 million years back,
a worm with eye spots-- gross.
But while the human keeps
the brain in one place,
the octopus doesn't.
They only have 500 million
neurons, about 1/20
of what our brains have.
But the cephalopod
brain works more
like an internet of brains.
While their main CPU is
only the size of a walnut,
each of their eight arms
contains packets of neurons
too.
These networked
smaller brain somehow
enabler a cephalopod to approach
the power of one central brain.
Researchers think each of
the collections of neurons
in the cephalopod's arms
can carry out instructions
independently and
think for themselves.
The suckers can attach
to things, exert forces,
and even smell stuff.
For example, octopi have learned
how to open jars and even
those little child-proof
drug bottles that
cause problems for
some adult humans.
Plus, these octopi aren't
taught to use tools.
They're solitary.
They don't have social groups
and only live for five years.
If you left a
four-year-old human along
with a prescription bottle full
of candy, what would happen?
Cephalopod?
Have that thing right open.
Not long ago, we considered
animals just dumb things
here for toys and entertainment.
But the closer we
look, the more we
find that as they
evolved alongside us,
they gained some skills that
seem pretty intelligent.
Tool use, forethought,
reasoning,
and puzzle-solving
skills have been
observed in elephants,
chimpanzees, dolphins, birds,
and octipi.
We may have made this awesome
giant brain do a lot for us.
But some of these animals
we share the planet with
are not so far behind.
So what do you think
of the humble octopus?
Smarter than you thought?
Are you surprised?
Type out your feelings into
that boxy thing down below,
and submit them,
so we can all see.
And while you're at it, click
the button that says Subscribe,
so you'll get all the D
News that's fit to film.
Thanks a lot.